cette chaleur cette chaleur hé Chicago qu'est-ce que
tu fais pour rester cool ça elle
pensera que ce n'était pas un rendez-vous
ça n'a pas causé énormément de problèmes
pour juste un autre frère qui parle doucement
c'est un associé d'été je vous l'ai dit
à propos de celui de Harvard Law, il
m'a invité à un événement communautaire alors comment
s'appelle ce garçon Barack Obama Barack je
ne dirais pas
bonjour tu es en retard en espérant que tu ne le remarquerais pas
je m'y attendais tu es en retard pour ton
premier jour de travail toi '  J'ai remarqué
que nous ne devrions pas non plus nous rendre à la
réunion, nous avons un peu de temps.
même intérêt c'est
gentil de ta part mais je suis une fille du genre crème glacée
qui n'aime pas la tarte tu retournes
ces lettres autour tu obtiens un
travail complètement différent reste avec moi maintenant
ils disent non nous disons que c'est pourquoi ça fait
un moment depuis  J'ai eu ce genre de
connexion avec la lutte de la vie réelle,
je veux juste en faire plus, oui, moi aussi  je me demande si
je peux écrire des livres ou occuper un poste d'
influence dans la politique des droits civiques peut-être
qu'il le veut bien sûr que
vous